will you uh to close out our hang
session play a little game with me of
sure naughty or nice you know I hate
games but I'll do it for all right thank
you so much thank
you okay now I have a little stocking
here so you could go in and and and I'll
just well I'll just grab the cards um
okay uh here just pick a card at at
random noty nice up okay oh you got the
nice card oh what's the best complim
ment you've ever received the best
compliment I ever received was from a
woman in ant Arbor Michigan don't
remember her name early on when I just
started the show and we just gone
National sent me a note saying watching
you be yourself every day makes me want
to be more of
myself is that not the that's I can die
with
that that's perfect okay pick another
card
okay oh naughty okay what's what
interview on the oah wi show got so out
of hand and
blown
out of
proportion oh
yeah this is in the early days it was um
my
sister slept with my sister's husband I
think it was that yes it was it it was
that and it was on that show
um afterwards Gail called me cuz Gail
used to watch every day and she said
look if you ever come home and you find
me in bed with Stedman don't be mad just
get a straight jacket and have me remove
cuz you will know that I have lost my
[Laughter]
mind okay pick
another okay it goes on oh naughty if
you're on a hike and you have to go to
the bathroom where do you go I'm
definitely going behind the bushes thank
you me
too okay one more one more okay this one
okay what's the most romantic thing
stepman has
ever
done for me um I think the most romantic
thing is when we had five dogs now we've
lost four of them um on every
Valentine's Day he would sit down and
write cards from each of the
dogs two me and each of the dogs would
send their own
bouquet that that's the most rantic oh
that is romantic now you have a but
after about the fifth year I was like
okay you need to move on to something
else like I I got the car I got that's
nice that's nice let's move on to some
no speaking of stemman Gail cards you
have a birthday coming up yeah a
milestone birthday it's huge and I don't
know what I'm going to you going to ask
me tell me what I'm going to do yeah I
don't know what I'm going to do I feel
so much pressure I was going to for my
60th birthday I came close to having a
birthday party and then the list became
so I was so anxiety written with the
list so I then decided I'm not going to
have the party okay so now I'm trying to
decide do I have just a dance party I
also like the idea of a few friends
joining me in the Redwoods because I
love trees but the problem is it's
January it'll probably be cold and then
I also really like the idea of just
being at home alone in my pajamas so I'm
trying to decide maybe what if you did
all three well you can't do the Redwoods
and dance party I don't think I don't
know how you do that in the could you
have a dance party in the redwoods in
pajamas
yeah I couldn't be more serious whatever
it takes for us to shake it tail feather
in honor of you would be I kind of like
shaking the tail feather I think so who
doesn't want to dance it's like we got
to get just do that all night long all
night
[Applause]
[Music]
long